in questo video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo
ritocchi cos'è successo tirato un calcio
fortissimo al cestino pazienza ed oggi
ragazzi carico un video che avevo
registrato tipo sapete che ogni tanto ci
sono le volte in cui gioco con gli amici
cazzeggio e registro no ecco questo
video charo da parte da una vita e mezza
e sono io che cazzeggio con i miei amici
c'è anche anima in mezzo e vi lascio al
video perché tanto non ha senso di
esistere
allora 0 89 marco mai visto schiacciando
la faccia
tutti contro marco pisellini vieni qua
metti l'audio e senti che bel rumore che
fa quando prende a schiaffi questo palo
senti che boccia ma cos'è ea delle
cartelle che si sente una di quelle
botteghe shaolin che picchiare tanti
beata gli alberi per diventare più forti
applichiamo tutti ha detto giorni poveri
che sembra prima ha piovuto gente che
che picchia sempre quel perché continua
a piovere gente che vi che ascolti a
caso perché alcuni 2 a picchiarlo sono
arrivati tutti ma che non lo so guidare
stoppa la rendimenti adesso tu vedi in
alto a destra che ci sono le indicazioni
devi andare a sw che serve sud ove si fa
quello ma paula si sta drogando cavola
dice uno che mi mette le mani come se
non dovessi risparmiare ma dove sei
è uno che che è caduto nella nostra zona
ha alzato le mani come se lo dovessimo
risparmiare aspetta che lo uccido perché
se una persona cattiva
poi ho preso acquistato lo uccido sono
una persona cattiva ragazza andate fermi
e girate a sinistra siamo qua qua questo
chi vuole stuprare aiuto ma se la coppia
ma perché lui è bello grosso nel senso
che vi pare che si è capito tutto ci
mettiamo orago è contrariato se ne vai
con l'ascia 40 ecco vecchio e titubante
va avanti e si gira non sta ben capendo
che cosa succede spesso ti caso andiamo
allora adesso questo gioco funziona così
quando hai sopravvissuto come il mio
italiano alla caduta poi muori
adesso dobbiamo farci solo ammazzare più
tardi possibile ma ho visto che mica
prima quando aveva solo caso c'era
niente che succedevano in due secondi
tipo vedevi un pregevole hunger games di
www ho una macchina di quelle che che si
guidano la guido io che sono bravo cosa
epica per altra pubblica è che vi
investe tutti gli anni nei quali ho
trovato come una r 15 qua dietro nel
match col grande popolo gravi se hai
preso un colpo solo è perfetta e capito
non si gioca
se il cui madonna ma che cazzo hai preso
ma non lo sono ma che cazzo fai presto
chi non sa guidare una macchina che
state facendo voi tanti problemi in tre
macchine guidate chi mi sono messa a
giocare se calmo chiamati perché si è
uscita dalla macchina sei scemo cazzo fa
no sono morto
alzato morto io l'ho ucciso ma ti giuro
era nascosto un albero pianale trono
dove si si si
qualcuno tank i demoni hanno inciso ha
peccato perché era buona la cosa ha
ucciso i due sono una persona forte e
munizioni benvenuto al nodo alla gola
sono sceso iniziato a sparare come un in
dirige mi hai lasciato nella macchina
con un povero stronzo quando sono andato
fuori dalla collina ex i baby sexy ma mi
girano con gilet anno con grandi cose
quando le giornate saranno perfette
anima mi auguro che una ragazza che
c'era da demon bazooka che ovviamente
uscito quindi siamo in quattro in che
direzione in che direzione è uguale a
ieri
subito sotto io lotterò sul tetto di
questo ea e prego iddio 42 arco non è
che una merda alcuna merda lasciano
diciamo lo zaino buono ma come ma da
amiche gli ho sparato alla schiena
questa si è girato e ucciso
numero maturare una bruttissima sacco di
merda ma dai
porca [ __ ] aveva solo gioco di merda
ma si minchia questo è morto ma si no
succo invece secondo me succo pagine
putrefatte non parlo alle ragazze ciao
come stai
tutto bene ora questo che stai mutande
che che vuole la vagina ecco vedi come
come attratta dalla vagina
ora l'uomo che cosa fa per la vagina
ok ragazzi allenatori carichi est sudest
subita non sono al piano di sopra che
tutto grosso praga marco ma mi farà
entrare prima o poi ma la roma non ha
fatto entrare dai ci credo ma adesso
aspetta che incazzato che sono ammazzo
mio amico non riesca ad ammazzare i nac
i miei amici sono una persona scarsa o
serie basta che dobbiamo fare una
partita che duri più di 30 secondi è
quello che guardo faccio birdwatching lo
reali per terra sono dei loro vini
e vero guarda che bello come il sole
stiamo per partire ragazzi questa sarà
per la partita che ci permetterà di
trovare la [ __ ] nella vita siete pronti
vai che vinciamo tutte poi andiamo a
trovare belen rodriguez
decido io seguitemi andiamo a i tre
palazzi perché voi decidete le cose non
capisco
sono caduto dentro la loro e ti faccio
vedere la cosa del più bello che tu
possono vedere petto nudo con i palazzi
a cosa fai
monica vin diesel ripulire le mani ai
pugni nelle mani dalla ligue entriamo
entriamo uno spaccato tutto di
prepotenza siamo entrate senza neanche
la tua rendono busto lo trovato perché
c'è qualcos'altro che può somigliare a
una pistola e basta un arco
grazie siamo tutti qua uno nudo uno nero
1 col casco è uno vero paga diciamo
forse ne abbiamo tutti sotto sotto tutti
sotto che il gas ci prende cazzo a
correre maninalto manco fossimo indiana
vale sta scappando dalla puglia non si
tira su le mani o munizioni ho bisogno
di erbe e allora te la lascio
quaquaraquà guardavano e miss con uno
spazio eccole qua veniva bene anima
vieni anima beni anima e questo è uno
zaino questo invece un po un po tratto
pompa guidato ti ho fatto prendere lo
zaino e io non ce l'avevo fantasmi sasha
cori corri corri corri come noi siamo in
saprò fisciano mai correre male perché
mi moriamo ma sempre stando lontani no
perché c'è il gas e che è vicino cosa
fai fatto tanto cemento che abbiamo mai
scemo in quell'uomo uscire il volo fa il
volo file onorevoli g
ma così è volo vorrei fare come volo
scrive marco la bella luca bravo cazzo
porca [ __ ] questo è il mio uomo
eravamo salvi perché aveva una cazzo di
macchina gesù cristo neanche questa
bravo ma ci sta anche sul nostro natale
ho capito ma non avevamo e guarda che
fine fa è più realistico
abbiamo fatto quanti metri con quella
cazzo di macchina 2009 sono passati sono
in f5 o c'è un 8 nevicherà in pietra e
non posso perché per uno scherzo da
ragazzi fate il giro lungo dal lago giro
lungo dal lago ormai luca andato
lasciamolo come dei veri compagni di
squadra facciamo morire non è morto
hanno colpito uno a morte ma non è morta
sei andato a filo hanno colpito una
morte ma non è morto un grandissimo non
ci sono beh dai ce l'abbiamo fatta sono
forti
sto sanguinando aia hai già preso la
roba che avevano non la prendo io sì
corriere se correte correte decoriamo
poi guardiamo ad accordi di marzo nord 9
scorri lascia core i9 e mettiti un kit
se ce l'hai o tre quattro band e di fila
e poi con ricavi sono salvati anch'io
sono solo allora di effetto io qua
spesso occorre avere un po ce l'abbiamo
fatta per niente praticamente perché
ricordate di credito in cancrena già
giusto mi sento zoppo tutto nudo tutto
che corre tutto con levan iraldo è il
fra i muscoli una r prende un colpo no
live id lascio dai più per un colpo
basso non voglio essere trovandomi anche
bravo ragazzo lasciato si sa ancora chi
è quello che ancora nel
questo nella carta o attenzione
bombardamento a noi è troppo guarda qua
no però attenzione che lei è troppo
cadere andranno tutti la ragazzi quali
cerca [ __ ]
no perché 5 aspettiamo un attimo perché
ciò perché noi siamo scarsi e 5 no
conviene che ci infiliamo in casa e
guardiamo da finestre
c'è una macchina facciamo barricati in
casa e
sei pronto buongiorno quelli non sono
scesi ed ero da solo quindi mi sono
trovati a che arriva dentro dentro
mentre tutti gli enti tutti dentro
non lo so tutti dentro penso proprio di
sì ragazzi sono fermati qui davanti a me
sta bene anche lì eccoli cazzo cazzo
stanno lì a fuoco anima nota è venuto
fuori che se lo compagni non fare così
insomma neanche affamata e ci abbiamo
circondato dio prova ancora a vincere
per la forza cioè non cedo riuscito nel
giocatore è ucciso 10 sono morto anchino
non ho ucciso sta scherzando niente
siamo forti gay friendly sono stato
ucciso dai gay friendly
ragazzi questo è questo non aveva senso
di esistere però c'è lavori ce l'avevo
registrato non sono anche se si può dire
in italiano però va bene chi se ne frega
ce l'avevo da una vita altro video
quindi trovo che volevo assolutamente
caricarlo prima o poi niente ragazzi 6
video è piaciuto va sui tassi documento
è un mi piace anche a pagina di facebook
come vidotto prescrizione senza esiti
felici migliaia che cazzo ma ancora di
una supplica pace a tirarla no no
[ __ ] è come cazzo si fa ambo le pile
in terra io veramente da una settimana
più o meno non registra perché tutta la
roba che avete visto nella scorsa
settimana avevo già registrata mi chiami
sembra non ricordarmi non così come si
parla è una roba come quando smetti di
scrivere per un periodo non ti ricordi
di momenti di scrivere o forse una cosa
che succede solo a me scegliamo prossimo
video bella ragazza prima che diventi
troppo trash